on this saturday night the fear of a new
strain in the uk
it moves faster and infects more people
it could be
up to 70 percent more transmissible
than previous streams now parts of
britain are in full lockdown
and christmas is cancelled the holiday
rush
before more ontarians are put into
lockdown
people who get infected over the
holidays may not have a hospital bed in
january
why experts say just stay home plus the
learning curve from the front lines
what doctors have discovered since the
pandemic began
and wi-fi on the moon the mission
underway so
astronauts can phone home
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us tonight a new faster spreading strain
of kova 19
is bringing holiday plants to a halt in
parts of britain
the new variant was first reported
earlier this week
it's common for viruses to mutate here's
what we know about this strain
it's not considered deadlier however it
is 70 percent more
transmissible in london for example the
strain has been linked to
62 percent of new covet 19 cases
so as of midnight london east england
and the southeast
move into a new tier 4 alert level
forcing families
to cancel christmas as crystal gomezing
reports all of the united kingdom
will soon see lockdowns put in place we
don't want
to as i say to to
ban christmas to to cancel it
and i think that would be frankly
inhuman it is with a very heavy heart i
must tell you we cannot
continue with christmas as planned
it took just three days for this
political 180
a new emergency lockdown in the u.k is
set to throw
millions of lives into turmoil as prime
minister it's my duty to take
difficult decisions to do what is right
to protect
the people of this country britain's
labor leader supports protection
measures but is appalled by the
government's handling of the pandemic
the prime minister has a habit of
pushing away challenge
of refusing to see a problem until it
later confronts him and i think
lots of families will be saying how has
this come about at the 11th hour in this
way
starting sunday london east and south
east england will move into the toughest
set of coronavirus restrictions
now known as tier iv all non-essential
business must close and people have to
stay home
that means millions of canceled
christmas get-togethers
gatherings will be permitted in the rest
of england and wales as well as scotland
but only on christmas day and right
after december 25th
wales scotland and northern ireland will
go into lockdown
this week alone more than 173 thousand
people
tested positive for covet 19 in the uk
and there is a new strain of the virus
circulating
it's up to 70 percent more transmissible
than the original
the highest occurrence has been in
southern england
in order to reduce the risk of more of
this strain being imported into scotland
we intend to maintain
a strict travel ban between scotland and
the rest of the uk
earlier saturday anti-lockdown
demonstrators clash with police on the
streets of london
the new restrictions will only add to
mounting frustrations
crystal gomencing global news london
[Applause]
italy has ordered a nationwide lockdown
over christmas and new year's to stop an
expected surge in cases over the holiday
season
the entire country is now under red zone
restrictions
non-essential businesses like
restaurants and bars are closed
and people can only travel for work and
emergencies
italy has the highest death toll in
europe more than 68 000 people have died
since the beginning
of the pandemic restrictions are being
tightened in hot spots in canada
today this country surpassed half a
million cases of coven 19
since the pandemic began alberta ontario
and quebec have the most active cases in
the country
according to yesterday's tally ontario
premier doug ford is holding two days of
emergency meetings
as infections mount in that province but
as morgan campbell reports despite the
appeals to stay home
many are heading out to fulfill their
holiday needs
with the lockdown looming and christmas
just days away many flocked to limeridge
mall in hamilton
about an hour west of toronto it's busy
land a lot of line some stores are
asking like
do you know what you want to buy right
away instead of
like letting shoppers browse the stores
there will be
no more browsing come monday as hamilton
locks down
joining toronto peel windsor essex and
york region nearly all non-essential
businesses will be forced to close
including much of the retail sector
restaurants and
personal care services this closure of
business
is going to be helpful but it is not the
only measure that people have to adhere
to it
has a lot to do with the social
interactions that we're seeing in our
community hamilton has seen a 40 percent
increase in daily covet case counts
as toronto and peel region continue to
report
triple digit numbers on a daily basis
the ford government has indicated that
more lockdown measures and restrictions
will likely be announced
come monday medical professionals have
said that this would be the most
ideal time to implement lockdown
measures across
all of southern ontario due to the fact
that
many take holidays school is on a break
and
many sectors ramp down production this
is actually a very reasonable point in
the year
people spend time at home spend time
with their kids
and so you know you all you have to do
is you know be a bit more aggressive
during this time it's not going to be
horribly inconvenient
my fear is that people who get infected
over the holidays may not have a
hospital bed in january when they need
it
earlier this week the ontario hospital
association
called for immediate action to curb the
spread of infection
as many hospitals are nearing their
breaking points
meantime ford is hosting an emergency
meeting with hospital leaders
throughout the weekend to discuss next
steps morgan campbell
global news hamilton there is hope that
a vaccine will make the difference in
the fight against kova 19 but after the
virus has run rampant for nearly a year
there's a lot of work to do as david
aiken reports vaccination programs are
now underway across the country
as many regions struggle to cope with
rising case counts
no feeling it's just great you didn't
feel anything
a little bit but not much well that's
cool i'm used to getting needles
in all her 84 years colette govan
has never had a needle like this one
she's the first in new brunswick to get
the first dose of the pfizer coven 19
vaccine
as a resident of a long-term care home
government and hundreds of thousands
like her
across the country are in the top
priority group for the vaccine
and right after govan new brunswick
authorities administered first doses
to an emergency room doctor a paramedic
a nurse to seniors
and an intensive care nurse all members
of the key
high priority groups for vaccines in
that province
and others i feel more at ease
now going to work because there's always
a chance of like an unknown
you don't know who's coming through the
doors
and i'm just really happy that i can
protect
myself but the race to vaccinate enough
canadians to make a dent in case counts
or
mortality numbers will be a marathon run
at a slow pace
you're probably looking at pretty steady
or even increasing mortality
until you get most of the way through
more than half the population for sure
and i would think i would think closer
to three quarters after a week in which
vaccination programs got underway less
than
ten thousand canadians have now been
given the first
of two doses of the pfizer biontech
vaccine
rising case counts for putting stress on
hospitals in many parts of the country
canada's public health agency said
saturday there are about
3 200 canadians in hospital
because of covet 19 including 650
in intensive care units icu beds are in
such
short supply in edmonton for example
that at a children's hospital there
patients in pediatric incentive care
units have been moved
to make way for critically ill adult
patients
and meanwhile the country waits for the
approval of the moderna vaccine and
health canada hopes to give it the green
light next week
david aiken global news ottawa
in the u.s millions of doses of the
moderna vaccine
are already on their way to hospitals
where doctors and nurses are in full
crisis mode
the country's death toll from the virus
is close to 315 thousand
now congress is meeting in a rare
saturday session
debating an aid package to help the
millions of americans
struggling jennifer johnson has the
latest from washington
with christmas just days away and
millions visiting relatives
wait lines for kova 19 tests and several
states are up to eight hours long
for three days in a row the u.s has
broken records for new infections
while deaths rise to staggering levels
it's heartbreaking quite honestly
young people old people
people that i'm just now meeting
and watching their families be
devastated
but more weapons to fight this pandemic
are coming after the u.s food and drug
administration approved a second vaccine
modernist late friday it is 94 effective
and unlike the pfizer biontech vaccine
does not require extreme cold
refrigeration we've determined that the
vaccines known to potential benefits
clearly outweigh
its known potential risk six million
doses are already rolling out
20 million by the end of december an
accelerated schedule as a handful of
state leaders complained
they received far fewer pfizer biotech
doses than expected
so to the governors to the governor's
staffs
please accept my personal apology if
this was disruptive
in your decision making the federal
government is promising more doses soon
as hospitals including now johns hopkins
and baltimore
run out of icu beds we will crush
this outbreak that has really terrorized
us
for the last 11 months as doctors battle
to save lives
congress is in a battle to save
livelihoods republicans and democrats
have been locked in negotiations for
weeks over a 900 billion
coronavirus aid package extending
unemployment benefits and protection
from evictions
the american people have already waited
for more assistance longer
than they could afford a vote is
expected sunday u.s president donald
trump has promised to sign the bill
immediately
an early christmas present for millions
of hurting americans
jennifer johnson global news washington
still ahead we talked to canada's
foreign affairs minister about china's
coercive
diplomacy
the global pandemic is top of the agenda
for canada's foreign affairs minister
francois philippe champagne had a frank
conversation with our mercedes stevenson
about the challenges facing this country
our ottawa bureau chief joins us now to
tell us about that talk
and trying to navigate all this
uncertainty mercedes
robin minister champagne said that 2020
showed us both the
fragility and the resilience of
canadians with our lives
upended in so many ways by the covet 19
pandemic
on the foreign affairs front that meant
repatriating tens of thousands of
canadians
back home he told me it was a humbling
experience
very much aware that he and his team
were the lifeline that so many canadians
abroad were reaching out for
and that that meant taking some pretty
extraordinary measures
i got a call from one of the airlines
they say minister can you help us open
the air space
and nothing prepares you for that you
know i'm a lawyer i'm i'm
i'm i'm i'm a public servant but in a
way
i i i've never done that in my life and
then i got probably become
somewhat of a travel agent for everyone
trying to open airspace making sure
people could get space
and our diplomats and our people and our
civil service really stood up to the
test
of course there are two canadians who
still aren't home yet
michael kovrig and michael spavor both
detained arbitrarily in chinese prison
the trudeau government has recently
taken a harder line on china
vowing not to bow to what has been
called coercive diplomacy
i asked minister champaign why there was
a shift towards that harder tone
here's how he explained it china of 2020
is not the china of 2018 or 16.
it's not just a metaphor it is the
realization of colleagues around the
world i do speak with foreign ministers
on a daily basis
and everyone is facing the same issue is
that things have been shifting
uh we we've seen a more coercive
diplomacy we have seen
probably one of the worst form with
respect to the arbitrary detention of
michael covering and spaver
and the way to respond to that is to
stand united to speak with one voice
well the government still hasn't gone as
far as sanctions which some have
suggested
minister champaign told me he's hopeful
that international pressure on china
to release the two michaels will see
them back on canadian soil
as soon as possible robin mercedes
stephenson in ottawa and you can watch
the full interview with canada's foreign
affairs minister on the west block with
mercedes stephenson tomorrow
right here on global the detention of
the two canadians is considered tit for
tat after the arrest of mong wang zhou
in vancouver
the cfo of huawei has now launched a new
argument to avoid extradition
to the united states hmong's defense
team claims canada can't be complicit in
an attempt by american authorities
to punish a foreign national for actions
that have no real connection
to the united states it's a complicated
case with international implications
mung is accused of lying to an executive
of hsbc
in hong kong about the relationship
between huawei and its subsidiary
skycom which was doing business with
iran the u.s
argues the money being exchanged
involved the american banking system
and therefore was a violation of u.s
sanctions against iran
still ahead the changes to copa 19
treatments that are helping patients and
those
on the front lines
you're watching global national
it's been nearly a year since the wh
first reported a mysterious
pneumonia-like illness
that was making people sick in china
ever since frontline healthcare workers
have been on a steep learning curve
battling an unknown and invisible enemy
as jeff semple reports from inside one
of toronto's hospitals
doctors are quickly developing novel
ways to fight back
alexandra brill was pregnant just days
away from her due date
when she tested positive for covid19
now i'm pregnant and i have covered and
i'm at the end of my term
and i'm about to give birth what's going
to happen during the first wave of the
pandemic abril's diagnosis would have
also
shaken hospital staff infected mothers
in some hospitals were kept away from
their newborns for up to two weeks
but babies have proved remarkably
resilient
overall outcome outcomes have looked
very good
abril's daughter was born on her final
day of quarantine and they were allowed
to go
home together the baby
tested negative i think as long as mom
uses the proper precautions
then you know keeping mom and baby
together are the most important
thing over the past 10 months staff at
this toronto hospital have had a crash
course in covid 19. we know how to treat
it better
dr jamie spiegelman works in the
intensive care unit which is nearing
capacity
half his patients have covered 19.
this 69 year old isn't getting enough
oxygen so the team performs a delicate
dance
carefully flipping him onto his stomach
increasing his chances of survival
patients also now receive steroids such
as dexamethasone
but despite all they've learned we don't
completely understand it and i don't
think we'll understand it until it's
over
doctors point to the unexpected case of
delroy noble
that's him back in may on a ventilator
in a coma
just 29 years old noble was overweight
but otherwise healthy
his mother was also sick but with minor
symptoms
i spoke with the doctors and they said
mom
you have a real critical son
that that sink me but i still never give
up
doctors didn't expect noble would
survive but after
two months in a coma he suddenly opened
his eyes if you can hear me
can you blink twice
they call me and tell me that your son
is is um walking i said
my son wake up that's when i
jumped i was sitting and i jump here i
cry okay
now nearly eight months since he first
became sick he still relies on a walker
physically struggling but emotionally
upbeat
he's back home playing with his nieces
and showing no interest
in self-pity i made it out in the end so
that's all that matters
2020 was full of terrible stories but
some
still managed to find their way to a
happy ending
jeff's uncle global news toronto zero
gravity network up next the very long
distance plan
for space
when humans return to the moon nasa has
plans to bring a canadian on board
and that's not the only first in the
works that crew may be able to send the
first
text messages from space global's paul
johnson explains how scientists in bc
are working out the long distance
logistics
that's one small
all of us know the crackly transmissions
we got from the apollo moon landings
of the 60s and 70s the next time we hear
from people on the moon
it's likely to be in 4g and with full
bars
nasa and its partners around the world
are on track to return people to the
moon
in just a couple of years the artemis
program
will see a new rocket and capsule fly to
the moon for a series of missions
that will put more people on the lunar
surface doing more things
for a longer period of time and no
surprise
they're going to need to talk more the
crew member could take their phone
and call home they could text their kids
from the lunar surface from that phone
and part of how they'll do that
will be enabled by work done here in
vancouver where researchers at
sfu's poly lab for advanced
collaborative networking
have been working with the canadian
space agency and nokia
developing standards for a cellular
network on the moon
the sfu portion is led by stephen braham
who's been perfecting communication to
remote places
like the arctic for decades stephen bram
is without a doubt a canadian national
treasure
i think that all the nasa communication
people think that
we just love having stephen involved
with us
so you can see how this might make for
some awkward conversations
with cell providers here on earth people
might wonder
if they can get it on the moon why do i
get such lousy coverage
at my cabin how they justify roaming
charges now
though they may be getting the fanciest
cell phone plan
ever they'll need it artemis will be the
most
ambitious space program to date their
movements and research on the moon will
lay the groundwork
for trips to mars and beyond these are
calls
we won't want dropped paul johnson
global news
vancouver great story paul that is
global national for this
saturday i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is the skating rink at the
meadows community center
in edmonton thank you for watching we'll
see you back here tomorrow
[Music]
you